hey David when will you start going to
restaurants the gym the movies traveling
and doing all of your normal life after
coronavirus I don't know I've been
thinking about this a lot talking to
friends and family and I'm planning to
get an antibody test next week or the
week after and it's conceivable that my
behavior may be different if it turns
out that I already had the virus I think
that that might affect my behavior to
some degree but I'm not just thinking
about myself I'm thinking about do I
want to be seeing my parents when this
starts dying down because if so I
probably need to do the responsible
thing and not go to some of these places
particularly if I don't have the
antibodies if I want to be around my
parents so I think for me the gym seems
pretty far off that seems like a
cesspool of germs and contagion I never
go to the movies as it is the last movie
I saw was not the latest Star Wars but
the previous one is the last time I went
to the movies I think that was three or
four years ago here in Boston so I think
I'm fine without going to the movies I
don't really care about the movies for
me the big things really are seeing
friends particularly at beer gardens or
going to restaurants going to cafes etc
I'm feeling like if they are going to
start opening some of those up with
reduced capacity my favorite cafe said
we're gonna operate at 20% capacity and
the employees will wear masks and you
know it's kind of hard to have a mask on
when when you're eating or drinking but
I would probably go and sit with my
laptop if the numbers keep declining in
Massachusetts the way they have been if
in three weeks those places start to
open I'd probably go and sit with my
laptop for two hours have a coffee then
come home wash my hands and I I think I
would be comfortable with that
Travel is a real question mark I don't
know I had a bunch of trips canceled
including I was supposed to be in LA on
the Joe Rogan program last week and
Triad vacations planned I don't know
when that's going to resume but I will
probably just look at
you know when when we travels down air
travels down 95% my sense is what I'm
not gonna be the first person to get
back on a plane when I see the numbers
recovering particularly evaluating the
case cases in Massachusetts and where I
would be flying to I'll kind of make
that call when it comes to it I would
love to be able to go somewhere in
August at this point I don't know if
we'll still be in wave 1 or maybe
already in wave 2 or maybe things would
be okay to travel I don't know but I'm
not making any any sort of bigger
decisions about that right now
curious to hear where your mind is I
know I have I have friends who have been
traveling throughout and I have friends
who are saying they're not traveling
until 2022 or going to restaurants
period for any time in the foreseeable
future I guess I'm kind of in the middle
and I'm gonna make decisions on a
case-by-case basis right now I'm looking
to May 18 to see how much do cases
hopefully keep declining in
Massachusetts and will our governor
Charlie Baker open anything up on that
date let me know your thoughts we've got
a fantastic bonus show for you today get
instant access to the bonus show two
ways these are quick you go to join
pakman.com and just signup the coupon
code
20:20 now saves you sixty-six percent if
you want it sign up in under a minute
get the bonus show or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show also
takes under a minute gets you instant
access to the bonus show we'll see you
then or on Monday